I was thinking back on this week and
what an incredible new Z week this has
been for the country despite the fact
that as you know end of July early
August usually dead but the debates
showed us a lot about this Democrat
party where they are now where Obama in
some circles was considered to moderate
they didn't even mention Bill Clinton so
it's moving further to the left this
week provided plenty of evidence and we
were there to cover it for you and
you've all been so far ahead of the
curve even watching the show for the
past two almost two years now and I have
to say a special goodbye to one of our
great producers we're gonna miss her
very much Lauren Woodhull who's been in
the show since its inception is gonna be
going on and doing a lot of great work
for Fox nation she's actually going to
be producing our Fox Nation show Laura
and Raymond so she'll still be with us
but not in the day to day show Lauren
you've done a great job for us and
continue to do fabulous things for Fox
and all the loyal Fox viewers and Fox
Nation viewers